Our next experiment embraces one of the most dangerous forces of nature.
Almost four million people have watched red-hot lava meet ice.
We caught up with artist Bob Wysocki and geologist Jeff Karson...
...and their rumbling lava furnace...
...to ask them what they thought would happen.
I had no idea what it was gonna do.
No idea at all.
The first guess is always it's gonna explode,...
...always number one,...
...or it's gonna tunnel down,...
...it's just gonna dig right through the ice, melt a hole in the ice.
And of course, it didn't do any of those things.
I was stunned by what it did when it hit the ice.
You see the bubbles,...
...bubbles this big, and then there's bubbles within bubbles.
The "scrambled eggs from hell" is the way it looks in that video.
Just two things we just didn't really expect.